how does your parents feel if you date
somebody like um I mean at this point
they want me to get married they want
kids really know how it is yeah yeah I
mean my dad is like oh John you are
fatty I'm like yeah Dad he's like you
are 30. I'm not I'm not I don't
understand what you mean but I know it's
you know they just want I understand it
you get to percent you a stage of the
parent you want to know that your child
is going to be okay by themselves but
you also you want to know that whoever
their partner is is going to take care
of them as they're starting their life
and and you're going towards you know
kind of retiring and letting them do
their things so they they would love of
what they would love a beautiful woman
to come to my life and and and handle it